BRIAN QUINLAN: Hey, everyone.
My name's Brian.
Thanks, Gus.
And I'm a software engineer on
the App Engine Python team.
Four months ago, we released the
latest App Engine runtime,
Python 2.7.
And it's already in the last
four months, it now gets 47%
more applications than the
Python 2.5 runtime, which we
released four years ago.
So this talk is basically about
how you get the most out
of the new Python 2.7 runtime.
So I'm kind of targeting this
talk for people who know
something about Python and know
something about App Engine.
If you don't know anything about
either, this talk is
going to completely
go over your head.
And this is where the people
who are watching this on
YouTube have the
huge advantage.
They can just hit the Back
button and go find something
else to do.
The people here who are sitting
in the middle are
going to have to use some sort
of ninja skills to sneak by
people and find a new
session without
getting in people's way.
Even if this talk isn't valuable
for you, I actually
have App Engine plushies to give
away at the end as some
form of bribery.
AUDIENCE: Yeah!
BRIAN QUINLAN: You can't
pre-claim them.
They'll be first come, first
serve at the end.
There's actually more to the
Python 2.7 runtime than just
Python 2.7 language features,
which is actually why it's the
second point on the slide,
not the first.
So I'm going to talk
about four things.
One is our new library support
for the Python 2.7.
Then I will talk a bit about
just language features in
Python 2.7 that are useful for
web application development,
some of the limitations that
we've removed from the Python
2.7 App Engine runtime versus
2.5, and concurrent requests,
which is hard to explain
in one sentence.
But it's possibly the most
valuable feature that we're
adding to the Python
2.7 runtime.
So I'm going to start talking
about third-party libraries.
And I'm just going to leave this
slide up for a couple of
seconds, so people read that
I designed this part.
And then people laughed.
I have my acknowledgement.
And we can move on.
We actually have to start a
bit in the past to really
understand why this
is important.
This isn't actually
the Big Bang.
This is a picture of the
simulation of the LHC, Large
Hadron Collider, producing Higgs
bosons, because, if you
remember, this is all what
we were doing in 2008.
We were basically waiting for
the LHC to start and end the
entire universe.
Well, the App Engine
team actually
beat them to the punch.
And we released App Engine in
April of 2008 with Python 2.5
as our launch runtime.
So I don't know if you remember
what the environment
was like in 2008, but it
was pretty primitive.
There were Tyrannosaurus rexes
chasing Triceratops around.
Well not really, but we had some
pretty barbaric software.
Django hadn't hit 1.0 yet.
It's like the premiere
Python web framework.
WebOb, which probably represents
another half of
Python web applications that
are built on top of it, it
hadn't hit 1.0 yet.
And App Engine evolved.
We made our Datastore
much more reliable.
We offered an SLA.
We went out of preview.
But we were kind of stuck using
these older libraries
for backwards compatibility.
We had no real way of upgrading
without breaking all
of our existing applications.
And backwards compatibility
is something
we take really seriously.
It also meant that we couldn't
add features to some of our
own libraries for
the same reason.
We couldn't make changes that
we wanted to make, just
because they would have
broken people.
So the solution for this, well,
for the dinosaurs, it
was a big comet.
And for App Engine, it
was the release of
the Python 2.7 runtime.
This was our launch cake.
It was tasty.
And let me just jump
to the punch here.
So in Python 2.7 on App Engine,
anyone who's done any
App Engine development should
recognize this configuration
file, or at least the
top, non-red part.
It's basically we're saying,
we have an application that
I've creatively called
myapp and then just
some data for it.
It handles every URL pattern
with a script called "main."
And the new part is, we have
an explicit libraries
declaration at the end.
So this means my application
is dependent on Django.
And I really need version 1.2.
I'm explicitly depending
on version 1.2.
So version 1.2 of Django is not
the latest version that we
support on App Engine.
But the person who wrote this
application doesn't have to
care, because they've explicitly
stated, this is my
dependency.
And they can upgrade to a newer
version later, whenever
they feel like it.
It's under their control.
So this basically solves the
problem of us not being able
to provide newer software
due to reverse
compatibility problems.
You just explicitly state what
third-party modules you're
dependent on.
So let me make this more
concrete by showing you a
real, Hello World
web application.
So this is pulled out of the
tutorial for Python 2.5.
So you can see we start by
importing a very simple
framework that we wrote,
called webapp.
And this is actually the
framework I was saying that we
couldn't upgrade, or we had
problems upgrading for
backwards compatibility
reason.
We define a very simple handler
that, in response to
get requests, just outputs
"Hello World!".
We make an application object.
We define a main function that
runs the application object.
And then we do the standard
Python, if name equals, equals
main, run the main function.
It's simple.
And a lot of this
is boilerplate.
So if you look at the Python--
AUDIENCE: 2.7!
BRIAN QUINLAN: Ah!
Right.
So I have a terrible memory.
So I have audience plants
to remind me of things.
So the reminder here was this
code will work absolutely fine
in the Python 2.7 runtime.
You can just take this Python
2.5 application, and it will
run perfectly in 2.7.
But this is, if you were writing
new code, here was how
you would write it idiomatically
in Python 2.7.
So you can see I've replaced
the import
of webapp with webapp2.
So webapp2 is an open source,
lightweight web framework that
was strongly inspired by
Google's webapp Framework.
But the fact that it's versioned
like the other
third-party like I showed you
before-- so that means it
doesn't have to be strictly
compatible with the releases.
You can say I am dependent
on an exact version.
So in fact, it's so compatible
that the only thing I had to
change to make the example work
is I changed webapp to
webapp2 everywhere.
And you also might have noticed
that the example is a
bit smaller.
That's because all of the
boilerplate that came at the
end is no longer necessary
in the App
Engine Python 2.7 runtime.
This is because Python 2.7 can
natively speak WSGI, also
called "Wiz-gee." Well,
the Python 2.5 runtime
could only use CGI.
So If you don't know what any
of those mean, it doesn't
really matter.
Think of it this way, five lines
of boilerplate are gone.
Yay.
And here's what the
configuration would look for
Python 2.5.
I have defined my application,
version 1.
I'm using Python.
This first start is completely
standard.
It will be in every application
in the end.
I say every URL should
be handled by
my Hello World script.
And in 2.7, it looks
very similar.
The runtime has changed from
Python to Python 2.7.
I have to add this explicit
thread, safety declaration.
Right now, I'm just setting it
to false, which is kind of the
safe option.
And I'll talk a lot about how
you can set that to true at
the end of the talk.
The handler, the script changed
from helloworld.py to
helloworld.app.
I'll talk about why you make
that change later as well.
And finally, I say I'm dependent
on the third-party
library webapp.2.
And I want to use the latest
version, which is 2.5.1.
OK, but no one is going to make
a billion dollars with
creating a Hello World
application.
So this is my Google+,
some photos.
Here's me hiking with some
friends, holding a big rock.
And yeah, it's interesting.
And here, this is an App Engine
application I wrote.
And I just pasted the URL for
that picture at the end.
And here's a picture of me
hiking with friends as viewed
by The Predator two seconds
before it kills us all.
Has everyone seen the
movie Predator?
Oh, not everyone has
their hand up.
It had great one-liners like,
"Get to the chopper," and "If
it bleeds, we can kill it."
So anyway, I'm thinking
about calling my
new start-up Predigram.
I think we can probably flip it
for about $1 billion in a
year or so.
And so, if you have maybe
$50 million of VC
money, give me a call.
And unlike most developers, I
will show you the code for our
start-up before you even
have to invest.
But looking at the code does
commit you to investing, so
leave the room if you're--
ah, whatever.
So if you look at the first line
of this example-- this is
a complete example, by the way,
the entire application,
21 lines of code that
you can see I
squashed the imports together.
So the first line
is just imports
of core Python libraries.
And it's the next line that's
actually a bit more
interesting.
I'm importing NumPy, which is
a Python numeric library and
PIL, which is an imaging
library.
So NumPy was the third most
requested third-party library
for App Engine.
And PIL was the number one.
So both of those are now
supported in Python 2.7.
And I'm not going to go into too
much detail about how you
would actually do this kind
of image transformation.
The basic idea is I don't care
what the original colors in
the image are, I'm going to
replace them by my own color
palette, which I defined
in the beginning.
I'm using NumPy in a very
trivial way when I write 4H
and NumPy linspace.
That's basically I want a linear
interpolation between 0
and 1 and 256 steps, so I build
a 256-color palette.
And then, if you look in the get
handler for the request, I
take a URL, which is all the
stuff that comes after image
and the URL scheme.
I load it using the
Python URL lib.
I open the image I've
downloaded, convert it into
grayscale, replace the palette,
convert it into PNG
and output it.
And that 21 lines of code can
be yours for $50 million.
And the configuration--
this is what the configuration
looks like.
It's basically the same as what
we saw before, the same
initial five lines to define
the application.
Now I'm handling image slash
in my image space.
My script name changed a bit.
And I'm dependent
on NumPy, PIL.
And I'm still using webapp2.
OK, so those are some neat
libraries I touched on.
And webapp2 is useful,
but less neat.
Here is the full set of
third-party libraries that we
support explicitly in the
Python 2.7 runtime.
I'm not going to talk about them
all, but I'll point out a
few others.
So Jinja2 is a templating
library.
In the Python 2.7 runtime, we
had our own simple templating
system called webapp.template,
which was a very simple facade
over Django.
And our use of Django
was kind of sketchy.
It wasn't thread-safe.
It had some problems.
So we're actually recommending
people who like Django
templates and Django
configuration to just use
Django templates directly.
And if they want a very
compatible solution without
having to do Django
configuration, just use Jinja2.
lxml I should probably mention,
because it was the
second most requested
third-party library for App
Engine Python.
I only didn't create a demo for
it, because it's very hard
to make an interesting demo
that involves XML parsing.
But please contact me if
you can think of a way.
And then the rest is just--
there's more, but I'm not going
to get into them all.
So I will mention that
this is early days.
We released this runtime
four months ago.
So this is the set four
months after release.
This list will grow over time,
or you can expect it
to grow over time.
And we are responsive to people
filing feature requests
on our external issue tracker.
So you can see we package the
first most-requested module,
the second most-requested
module, the
third requested module.
You can kind of see there's
probably a pattern here.
Yeah, I think that's it.
Move to the--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BRIAN QUINLAN: Sorry?
BRIAN QUINLAN: Ah.
Right.
See?
Audience plants,
very important.
So I also mentioned that these
are the libraries that we
provide explicit support
for you.
Python says it's kind of a
batteries included language.
We throw in some more batteries
that are included to
make it easier to do
web development.
But if there's another battery
you want, like your own web
application framework like Flask
or Bottle or whatever,
then it's no problem.
You just download
that yourself.
And it will get uploaded
with your application.
Thank you, audience plant.
OK, cool.
This is my favorite section.
There's things in Python 2.7
itself that are new that are
useful for web development.
And the great thing about this
is, basically, I can take
credit for work that
other people did.
So-- oh, more demo.
So this is my value add.
Having a billion dollar
company is cool, but
I want a bit more.
So I think this makes our
company worth $1.5 billion.
So before, I had to paste a URL,
and it would generate the
predator view of the image.
Now I can just take Google+ IDs
and go to this different
application, called Predator +,
and just paste the ID here.
And it'll show you a Google+
profile using Predator Vision.
So I think this will allow us to
make our own Google+ clone
that provides the high-contrast
colors that the
discriminating predator wants.
And we can completely corner
the extraterrestrial market
for Google+ or, at least,
homicidal extraterrestrials.
Anyway, value add.
Call me. $50 million
gets you in.
So here's the app that adds
that little feature.
Google+ has a JSON API.
Or sorry, it has a high-level
Python API and also just a
JSON RESTful API.
I am using the JSON API because,
basically, my example
would suck if I didn't,
because I'm trying to
demonstrate JSON.
So you access this profile URL,
filling in, you can see I
have user ID there.
You fill in the user ID with
the user's actual ID, that
number you saw.
And then let's look at
the actual code.
So in my get request, instead
of taking a URL, I'm
interpreting it as a user ID.
If we read this code from the
inside out, I'm taking the
profile URL and formatting it
using the passed-in user ID.
So Format is a feature
that wasn't
available in Python 2.5.
The next thing I'm doing is I'm
using a URL Open to load
the Google+ profile.
So there's a Timeout Argument
that is now available in
Python 2.7 for URL Open.
And that seems like a really
small thing, but it's actually
a huge thing for web application
development.
If you are using a Twitter API
or Facebook or whatever,
you're interacting with any
other service when you're
building your web application,
it sucks if it's taking them
10 seconds to handle requests,
if you are blocked for those
10 seconds waiting for them
to come up with an answer.
It's probably preferable to say,
look, I'll wait, in this
case, 200 milliseconds.
And if I don't get an answer
from them, then I'll just
serve some sort of degraded
response.
Well, in this particular case,
it's very degraded.
I redirect them to
a static image.
But you can probably do
something smarter than that.
So I'm using this
Timeout thing.
And finally, I'm using this new
C implemented JSON module
that's available in
Python 2.7 that
parses the Google+ profile.
There is the code.
By the way, this is a
programming demo hat trick,
three new features in
three lines of code.
And they're consecutive lines
of code, so it's actually a
natural hat trick.
No one cares about hockey
and-- anyway.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN QUINLAN: Thank you.
So finally, down here, you can
see I build the URL just by
extracting the image
from this.
The profile is a Python
dictionary now.
I look up the image
key, the URL key.
I split off all these
query arguments that
I don't care about.
And I've got a URL.
And then I just proceed,
like you saw in
the previous example.
There's good docs for the
Google+ API, if you're
interested in how you would do
something like this yourself.
OK, I'm kind of hurt,
actually.
You all laughed at my VC thing,
but no one actually
offered money.
So I'm going to go into banking,
because banking is
where the money's at.
Sorry, that was bad.
But I'm going to highlight
a few little things here.
So I'm trying to model a banking
account system here.
You can see that the first thing
that's kind of new, like
in the last couple of months
new, is I'm using a new module
called NDB.
So NDB is the new,
next-generation Python
Datastore framework.
It has some great features that
are really hard to see,
so I'll just tell
you about them.
So one feature is it does
implicit caching.
So when you're creating items
or looking them up, it'll
cache them locally
in local memory.
It has another level of caching
where it will use Memcache.
And then, finally, it will
use the Datastore
as persistent storage.
And that's done all
behind the scenes.
You don't have to worry about
how that actually works.
Another thing is it can be used
asynchronously, which I
guess I could show,
but I won't.
And I will show one feature,
because Guido van Rossum wrote
this, and he told me I had to.
And it's called Structured
Properties.
So you can see I have
an Account class.
And the second thing I have to
find, the most important
thing, the balance, how
much cash you have.
But above that, I've said
there's account_holder.
And the account_holder
has a Structured
Property, which is a contact.
And in this bit of code, I don't
have to define exactly
what a contact is.
That can be another NDB model
defined elsewhere, in this
case, another module
that defines
exactly what's in a contact.
And that can be reused across
different NDB entities.
So this is a huge boon for
people who are doing
complicated data modeling.
It means that they don't
have to have--
you don't need one entity that
defines 50,000 properties in
it, like everything that
you would need to
have a real bank account.
It means you can abstract
away content
into different modules.
OK, but here's where the
important stuff happens.
How do you transfer money?
So ignore that decorator on
the next line, the NDB
transactional thing.
So here's how our
function works.
So we're going to take
account_ID, where we're
transferring the money from,
another account_ID that we're
transferring to,
and an amount.
That's probably fairly
straightforward.
So we're going to actually,
given the ID, we're going to
look up the two accounts,
the from_account and the
to_account.
And then we're going to just
to update the balances.
So from_account gets the amount
deducted from it,
to_account has the balance
added to it.
If the from_account balance is
negative, then you get an
insufficient cash exception.
Otherwise, both of the
entities get saved.
Now let's look back at
the decorator, NDB
transactional xg=True.
So what this means-- and this is
a fairly new feature in App
Engine-- it means I'm defining
a transaction.
So when you're calling this
function, this is done in a
transaction.
Either both accounts will be
updated with the semantics I
defined here, or neither
will be.
And this is guaranteed.
So until recently, you could
only guarantee modifications
to one entity group
in a transaction.
Now you can do several.
This is a huge win for writing
this kind of apps where you
have to guarantee that
modifications are made to
several entities at once.
OK, I've written this code, but
who knows if it actually
works or not.
So one thing that a lot of
people don't take good
advantage of in App Engine is we
have a really sweet testing
framework called Testbed.
And it basically allows you to
write unit tests, but using
the simulated App Engine
framework, so you don't have
to do complicated mocking.
So let me skip over, basically,
all of the imports,
the set up and tear down.
This is boilerplate that you can
get just by looking at the
Testbed documentation.
And let's look at this test
insufficient cache.
So basically, I create and store
two bank accounts, one
for the VC, which has $1 million
in it, and one for me,
which has $200 in it.
And then this next line is
kind of interesting.
This is a Python 2.7
testing feature.
It means the following code,
like the code within this with
block, I expect it to raise the
insufficient cash exception.
If it raises that exception,
it's working as intended.
And if it doesn't raise
that exception, it's
not working as intended.
And then I transfer the
money from the VC
account to Brian account.
But I want $5 million,
not $1 million,
which is all they have.
So it all fails.
So this assertRaises is
new in Python 2.7.
But this is like a tiny tip of
what's new for testing in 2.7.
Python 2.7 actually added over
20 new test methods.
They rethought how the framework
fits together.
There's a lot more places
where you can
inject your test logic.
So I would, if you're using
Python 2.7, look at the
release notes for it and look at
all the new testing things.
It's very easy to let testing
features slip by, unless
you're really keeping up.
There's a bunch of other stuff
that's added to Python 2.7.
So I asked some Python
people what they
thought was most important.
I started by asking myself.
And I thought this was the
most important thing, the
datetime, timedelta class gained
a total seconds method.
I added this myself.
I think this will revolutionize
Python
development.
It replaces the one-liner that
you had to use before.
I asked some other people, some
core Python developers.
I got this really excited
email from Guido.
It goes, Python 2.7 advantages,
class decorators!
Very exciting for him.
Alexander Motelli, author,
Python luminary,
"Multi-context with"
was his thing.
Brett Cannon, huge contributor,
"Dict and set
comprehensions." So what we
really learned here is that
core Python developers like
really esoteric features.
But I have some other
real users.
This conversation's going
on on my Google+.
So here's what some
people think.
"There was a big revamp
to itertools.
A lot of powerful features
there." "The collections
library has a lot of new classes
in it, like Counter
and OrderDict." "You have set
literals now." And someone
pointed out that the docs
are much better than
they were for 2.5.
OK, done taking credit time.
So next, I'm going to talk about
some of the limitations
we've removed from Python
2.7 versus Python 2.5.
So most of them are fairly
esoteric, but this is kind of
an interesting one.
Who here knows the Python
timeit module?
Oh, good.
I actually think
that's probably
the best Python module.
And I looked up who wrote it,
because I was going to send
them flowers or something.
But it turned out
it was Guido.
And I think he's got
enough credit for
the language already.
So it basically allows you to
run code many times and
generate timings for it.
So the code I'm testing
is code =.
And then I have this
Pickle dumps line.
So what that's doing is it's
taking a Python data
structure, serializing it, and
writing it into a string I/O.
And setup, the block above it,
defines the setup that's used
before that code is run.
Then I define the timer, which
takes the code in the setup.
And I basically run
this 5,000 times.
I do 10 trials.
And I take the fastest one.
And so I did this.
And I ran it in Python 2.5.
And I ran it in Python 2.7.
And the Python 2.5 output was
3.33, meaning that it took
3.33 seconds to execute
this benchmark.
And then I ran it again in
Python 2.7, which took 0.45
seconds to run this benchmark.
So you can see--
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN QUINLAN: Yay!
Yeah, be excited.
So you can see, in my previous
examples, like when I was
doing PIL image manipulation, I
was using cStringIO, a very
commonly used Python class.
cPickle is a lot less commonly
used, at least explicitly.
But we use it internally in
App Engine for things like
Memcache, when you're storing
data in Memcache and also when
you're doing things like if
you're using tasks to defer,
things like that.
So even if you don't use Pickle
directly, you can
expect your App Engine apps that
indirectly use it, their
performance to improve.
Most of the rest of this stuff
is a bit esoteric, so I'll
just skim through it.
So we have some new modules,
cPickle and cStringIO.
Before, in Python 2.5, they
were just aliased to their
slower pure Python versions.
We have imp.
Please don't use that.
It's kind of a dangerous module
to use, unless you
really know what you're doing.
Marshall, also fairly
esoteric.
We support bytecode modification
on Python 2.7.
So if you want to add go tos
to Python, you can do that.
Actually, I can't think of a
non-esoteric use for bytecode
modification either.
And finally, we have direct
support for compiled Python
files, so you don't have
to upload your
source in Python 2.7.
You can just upload
the compiled data.
Probably, you don't want to
do that most of the time.
But if you have a vendor who's
only providing you compiled
code, then you can just use it
without needing the source.
Or you can just re-negotiate
with your vendor,
which is what I do.
Finally, concurrent requests.
I like my tagline.
It's basically saving
you money while
making your app faster.
So we need a bit of
background here.
Basically, what concurrent
requests do is they reduce the
number of instances that
your application needs.
So an instance is basically a
copy of the Python interpreter
that's used to handle
your requests.
So this is from the App
Engine Admin Console.
I've clicked on the
Instances tab.
And it's showing me here that
I have seven instances.
And it's giving me some
data about them.
So for many applications, the
biggest charge that you're
going to get for App Engine is
going to be for the instances
that you're using.
So keeping your instance usage
low is potentially a big win.
So this is just kind
of a pro tip.
So if you're in your App Engine
dashboard, there's a chart.
And there's a little
pop-up there.
And buried in there is an item
called Instances, which shows,
broken down into 6, 12, 24, et
cetera, time chunks, how many
instances you're using, how many
you're getting charged
for and how many there
are total.
So App Engine will sometimes
keep some instances around and
not charge you for that, just
to handle extra load.
But you shouldn't
count on that.
That's just a thing we do, if
we have spare capacity.
And so you can see how your
instance charges are
changing over time.
OK, so let me explain
the actual feature.
So this is the way requests are
handled at a 50,000-foot
view without concurrent
requests.
So let's say you have an
application and you have one
instance, so one copy of Python,
that's not currently
handling a request.
So a request will come in
for your application.
And App Engine will go, oh,
I have a free instance.
And it will forward the request
to the instance.
That's probably what you
expected would happen.
So if you get another request
that comes in and that one
instance, which is the only
instance you have in this
example, is already busy
handling the first request,
then App Engine has to create
a second instance, wait til
that's created, and then forward
that request there.
So if you have two concurrent
requests, it basically means
you need two instances
to handle them.
So looking at the math, very
simply, if you have 10
requests per second, like every
second you're getting 10
requests, and each request takes
one second, then you'd
need 10 instances to handle the
load, if I did the math
right, which I think I did.
So with concurrent requests,
it changes a bit.
So your app receives
a request.
And the request is forwarded
to the instance.
And if you get another request,
the request is
forwarded to the same instance,
which then creates a
thread and handles the request
in that thread.
So this means, in this diagram,
we're serving twice
the traffic with a single--
I'm sorry, we're serving the
same traffic, but with half
the instances.
So the obvious question here
is, will this make my
application slower?
Because I have the same CPU
resources for one instance,
but I'm now sending
two requests for
it instead of one.
And the answer, of course, is
yes, this will make the
request handling slower.
I'm trying not to look at the
App Engine people who might be
glaring at me now.
But the slowdown is probably
much smaller than you expect.
And for, basically, the rest of
the talk, I'll walk through
an example where I load test
a real application--
and by real, I mean my Predator
application--
and see how it behaves.
So here's a reminder of,
basically, what the Google+
variation of the Predator
application does.
I removed some of the exception
handling, because
cool people don't do exception
handling, and it makes the
code too big.
And I've put comments
that break the code
out into three stages.
So first, we load the
Google+ profile.
And basically, when we're
loading the Google+ profile,
we're not using the CPU.
We're just waiting for a
network to get back to
us with some data.
Then we load the image,
the profile image.
And once again, we're just
waiting for IO there.
And finally, we use a ton of
CPU to decode the JPEG,
convert to grayscale, do a
palette substitution, and then
re-compress as PNG.
So if you look at this over
time, I did timing.
And of course, these timings
lined up perfectly on 100
millisecond boundaries.
It always takes exactly 100
milliseconds to load the profile.
It takes 300 milliseconds
to load the image.
And then it takes 100
milliseconds, exactly, every
single time, to transform
the image.
OK, I totally made
these numbers up.
No, I didn't make them up,
but they're obviously
approximations, based
on many runs.
And I've rounded to the nearest
100 milliseconds.
Now, if we look at this program
flow versus CPU usage,
we can see we start by basically
using no CPU.
We're just waiting
for a URL to be
downloaded from the internet.
And that continues the same
for when we're loading the
profile image.
We're just waiting for
the image to come
back from the network.
And finally, we have a big chunk
of CPU usage while we're
transforming the image.
So in this particular case, we
can see that we're spending,
basically, one fifth of our
request time using the CPU.
And the rest, it's idle.
So with that concurrent request,
that CPU time is
basically wasted.
There's just nothing for the
CPU to do while it's doing
this downloading.
So that's the theory.
Now let's load test it.
So I don't want to actually do
URL fetching in my load test,
because the performance
is too variable.
Downloading stuff from the
internet takes a variable
amount of time.
So I've cleverly replaced the
downloading with sleep
statements.
So I sleep 100 milliseconds to
simulate loading the Google+
profile and another 300
milliseconds to simulate
loading the image.
And I put a picture of a rock in
the application directory.
And that's the one
I transform.
So I upload this application.
And then I use a tool
called jMeter.
So has anyone used jMeter?
Oh, wow, lots of people.
So jMeter is basically
a load testing tool.
And basically what it does is
you tell it, create a number
of fake clients that hit
a particular URL.
And it simulates hitting
that URL.
And as soon as it's loading, hit
refresh, wait til it loads
again and keep hitting
refresh.
It's basically simulating
a person who
keeps hitting refresh.
And in this particular example,
I'm simulating 25
people hitting refresh
continuously on my Predator
application.
So at the top, I've copied out
the data that I got here.
So in this case, it's done 790
requests, so it's giving it a
throughput of 1,500 requests
per minute.
And the average and median
numbers you see on the right
are latency.
So the average request is taking
950 milliseconds to be
responded to.
So I actually did
this load test.
And I compiled a table
with my results.
So if you look at the top row,
this is just the default
configuration for
App Engine use.
It's what's called
F1 instances.
There are 600 megahertz
virtual CPUs.
And I generated the timing's
for that without concurrent
requests enabled.
So the latency that I measured
was, basically, one second, so
1,015 milliseconds.
It created 24 instances
to handle this load.
And I just normalized
the dollar cost.
To handle this load, let's
say it costs $1.
Now in the next line what I've
done is I've done the same
load test, but turning
concurrent requests on.
So you can see that latency
actually increased by 30%.
Kind of sucks.
But the number of instances
required to handle this
traffic went from 24 to 9,
which is a big reduction.
And finally, the normalized
dollar cost is $0.38.
So our latency increased
by 30%, but our cost
was reduced by 60%.
So this might be a trade-off
you're willing to make.
You might be saying, well, to
pay 60% less money, I'm
willing to make my users
wait 30% longer.
But if you don't like that
trade-off, you can bump up the
instance cost from
an F1 to an F2.
So an F2 is basically twice
as fast as an F1.
So we get slightly different
latency numbers.
We're now, instead of
being 30% faster,
we're a bit less than--
sorry, it's 30% slower with
concurrent requests on.
We're about 10% slower,
a bit less than 10%.
We're using eight instances,
instead of nine.
And our normalized dollar cost
is 60-something cents.
So this is also a possible
trade-off that you'd make.
Latency has only gone up a bit,
but you're still saving
30% of the cache.
And then I did a
final increase.
I jumped from an F2 to an F4
and reran the benchmark.
So in this particular case,
latency actually fell from one
second to 0.9 seconds, about.
Number of instances
went to six.
And due to a coincidence of
math, the normalized dollar
cost is the same.
So you have 1/4 of the
instances, but each of them is
four times more expensive.
So you end up with the
same dollar cost.
So you can see it, concurrent
requests, in this scenario,
are a win on, basically,
every level.
If you turn them on and switch
to an F4 instance, you would
get reduced latency,
so a better user
experience at the same cost.
Or you could choose to give the
user a slightly degraded
user experience from a latency
point of view and save
yourself some money.
And I will point out that this
workload is actually pretty
bad from App Engine's
point of view.
If you think about what these
requests are doing, they're
basically idling the CPU.
And then they're doing
a huge CPU spike.
So that's a very tough workload
for a scheduler to
deal with, because it's
like, oh, this
instance, it's doing nothing.
I can start packing
on requests.
And then suddenly, there's a
huge CPU spike that actually
lasts for quite a long time.
So there are other workloads
that have a more even mix of
CPU and IO.
And by IO, I don't mean
just URL fetch.
I mean Datastore, Memcache.
Anything where the CPU is not
used will generate a better
trade-off than the
one you see here.
So I've clearly convinced you
that concurrent requests are
awesome and that you
should use them.
So how do you actually do it?
So the first thing you have to
do is make sure that your code
is actually thread safe.
And thread safety is this huge
thing that I don't want to
spend too much time
talking about.
But basically, the easiest way
to get yourself into trouble
and make your code not thread
safe is to, basically, change
global variables without using
some sort of lock.
So has anyone figured out
what the problem with
this code is yet?
So I've cleverly decided to add
a cache of the images I've
already transformed before.
So basically, what I'm going to
do is, when a URL comes in,
I'm going to generate
the Predator image.
And then I'm going to save
it in this cache.
So if the URL is already in the
cache, which you can see
in the second line in the get
handler, then I'm going to
just output the cached
version.
Otherwise, I'm going to
compute the image as
normal in the end.
I don't want the cache
to grow forever.
So if there is greater than 10
items in it, I'm just going to
randomly throw an item away.
And then I'm going to store
the image I just
generated in the cache.
So the disaster here is I can
check to see if the image is
in the cache while a concurrent
request runs along.
And it removes that item
from the cache.
And then, when I get to the next
line where actually I'm
writing the cached item,
then I blow up, because
the value's not there.
So this isn't a comprehensive
examination of thread safety,
but this is the kind of pattern
that will screw people
up where they're mutating a
global variable without having
some sort of lock.
But I'm sure it'll be easy for
you to fix that, if you have
problems like this.
So just do that and then
go to step number two.
So step number two is
you need to define a
WSGI application object.
Probably, existing App Engine
apps will, pretty much,
already be doing that.
In all my examples, I've been
defining a webapp2 WSGI
application, but you can use any
WSGI application you want,
Django, Bottle, Flask.
WSGI is the dominant web
application standard for
Python, so you're going to
have no problems using
alternatives, if you want.
Then you basically take your
app.yaml file and you take the
name of your module, put it in
the script field, put a period
and then the application
name and you're done.
Surprisingly, this is not
the easiest step.
This is the easiest step.
You just take that thread safe
false I showed you before, set
it to true, and you have
concurrent requests enabled.
And you're all done.
Speaking of all done, I'm all
done, except for just let me
summarize what we've
talked about.
So with the Python 2.7 runtime,
you get a much nicer
third-party library
experience.
We support a bunch of libraries
that people have
been really asking for.
And we support it in a way
that's basically future-proof,
where we have an upgrade
path for them.
There's some Python 2.7 features
that are really
useful for web application
development.
And there's some other features
that are really
esoteric, but core Python
developers seem to like them.
We have fewer limitations
in the runtime.
And finally, we support
concurrent requests, which
have the potential to save you
some serious money and/or make
your apps faster
for your users.
So thanks.
Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN QUINLAN: Thanks,
for Wikipedia, for
the dinosaur pictures.
Thanks to the Python community
for making Python.
We couldn't really do App
Engine without it.
And thanks for all you
App Engine people,
for making cool apps.
AUDIENCE: Questions?
BRIAN QUINLAN: Absolutely.
Could you go up to the mics,
just so this is recorded?
AUDIENCE: So I have
a question.
Do you plan or is there any
plan to support additional
runtimes, namely PyPy?
BRIAN QUINLAN: That's a great
question that I won't answer.
We're thinking about new
runtimes all the time, but we
can't really talk about whether
we're actually going
to support them or not.
Sorry about that.
You can bug our product
management folks-- for
example, there's one right
there-- and try and beat some
sort of answer out of
him, if you want.
AUDIENCE: A second
quick question.
BRIAN QUINLAN: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Can you use
duck tests with
the unit test framework?
BRIAN QUINLAN: I haven't tried
it, but I can't see why that
wouldn't work.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
BRIAN QUINLAN: No worries.
Maybe alternate mics?
AUDIENCE: So you talked about
concurrent requests.
One of the common requirements
was to reduce the cost by
having concurrent requests.
BRIAN QUINLAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: The other most
important thing is the
functionality that comes with
concurrent requests,
especially with stateful
applications.
So earlier, you never had to
go to the same server.
It always goes to a
different server.
BRIAN QUINLAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But if you have to
have a server with data
already in memory and you have
to go back to the same server,
that's not possible
with App Engine.
Now, with concurrent requests,
that's possible.
But then it's not possible
with App Engine.
BRIAN QUINLAN: So it's not
possible in the model you're
thinking about.
So App Engine will send
concurrent requests to one
instance, but it won't
do that forever.
So say you have, for example, a
million concurrent requests.
It's not going to send a million
requests at one Python
[INAUDIBLE].
It will start ramping
up new ones as the
instances get saturated.
So you won't have shared memory,
potentially, across
those shared requests.
Now we have another thing
called Servers.
I don't know if you've
looked into that.
AUDIENCE: Backends?
BRIAN QUINLAN: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: You mean backends?
BRIAN QUINLAN: Sorry,
backends.
Sorry, my mistake, backends.
And they basically allow you to
have some fixed number of
backends with, potentially, a
large amount of memory to deal
with this kind of thing.
AUDIENCE: OK.
BRIAN QUINLAN: But actually,
maybe you could come by the
booth afterwards.
And we could talk about this.
I'm curious what your
use case is.
So could you wait a second?
[INAUDIBLE] will switch sides.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I have a question.
BRIAN QUINLAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In your code you show
that you were using the
webapp to HTTP request
handler.
BRIAN QUINLAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In order to use
concurrent requests, do you
need to use those handlers?
BRIAN QUINLAN: Absolutely not.
You can use any thread safe WSGI
application framework.
So you can use webapp2, Django,
Bottle, PIL, whatever.
AUDIENCE: And I have a side
question to that.
BRIAN QUINLAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In the webapp2,
you define a get method.
Do those methods map to
the request type?
BRIAN QUINLAN: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like as opposed--
BRIAN QUINLAN: Yeah,
sorry, they do.
So if you want to handle get
requests, you define a method
called get.
If you want to handle post,
you define a method called
post, push for push, et
cetera, et cetera.
AUDIENCE: OK, so it's like a
magical wrap kind of thing?
BRIAN QUINLAN: Yeah, yeah, but
if there's a framework that
you're more comfortable
with, just use it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
BRIAN QUINLAN: Not that
webapp2 is bad
or anything, but--
AUDIENCE: So how does the
saturation of an instance, how
is that determined?
What I'm specifically wondering
is, if you have
requests that are really
variable with their latency--
so in your benchmark example,
they were all uniform latency
per request--
but if that's highly variable,
say you have some that are a
couple of hundred milliseconds,
some that are
over a second, how is that going
to play into threading?
BRIAN QUINLAN: So it's hard to
give you an answer that's not
going to get dated, because
we want to be able to make
scheduled improvements without
committing ourselves to a
particular implementation
strategy.
But right now, we're basically
sampling the CPU usage, back
by, I think, a couple hundred
milliseconds.
And we're using that to judge
whether the instance can
handle more requests.
So this is why this is
pathological, because it
doesn't really have a long-term
history of how
requests have behaved
over time.
AUDIENCE: Mm-hm, I see.
BRIAN QUINLAN: Well, was that
sufficiently precise?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think that makes sense.
That's what I was
wondering about.
BRIAN QUINLAN: Yeah.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
the new NDB module.
BRIAN QUINLAN: Yep.
AUDIENCE: And you talked about
a new property type there.
BRIAN QUINLAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What were the
differences between that and
the reference property,
in short?
BRIAN QUINLAN: So a reference
property creates
two separate entities.
So it's basically, you have two
separate entities in Datastore.
And a reference property
joins them up.
What a structured property does
is, basically, it puts
them into the same
logical entity.
But it's an organizational
thing, not a
Datastore level thing.
So it helps you with data
modeling, but it doesn't
actually change the entity
abstraction.
I felt I explained that
really poorly.
Feel free to ask a question that
gets me to clarify what I
meant there.
AUDIENCE: No, that's
clear enough.
Thank you.
BRIAN QUINLAN: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: So structured
properties and indexing,
what's the impact on the number
of Datastore writes
per-- yeah.
BRIAN QUINLAN: It essentially
doesn't change anything.
So if you have an indexed
structured property--
sorry, let me phrase
it in another way.
Whether a property appears as
a structured property or in
the top level of a model, it
has the same cost from an
indexing point of view.
You have another question.
AUDIENCE: But is it going to
create an index for each
property within this
structure?
BRIAN QUINLAN: If the properties
within the
structured property are defined
to be indexed, then it
will create an index for
each of those fields.
So basically, if you imagine a
structured property, like you
have a model and you have a
group of code that's logically
combinable, like an address,
and you want to have a line
one, line two zip code,
whatever, if you extract that
out and put it in a structured
property, it doesn't change
the indexing behavior at all.
I hope that helped.
AUDIENCE: Yep.
BRIAN QUINLAN: Sorry, sorry,
structured property,
structured property.
Did I say referenced property?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BRIAN QUINLAN: Well, no, because
now you just have an--
sorry, the question was, does
referenced property change the
indexing characteristics?
And the answer is, with
referenced property, you have
another Datastore entity
that represents the
other set of data.
And that other entity will
still get indexed.
So no, no, it won't change the
indexing characteristics.
AUDIENCE: So it might be a while
since I looked at this,
but is it possible now, with a
third-party library, to have
one that connects to an external
service using a
custom TCP protocol?
BRIAN QUINLAN: No, it's not.
AUDIENCE: And is it ever
going to be possible?
BRIAN QUINLAN: Ever going to
be possible is such a hard
question to answer.
AUDIENCE: Well, is there any
plans to make that possible?
BRIAN QUINLAN: Oh, it is on
the road map, so yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BRIAN QUINLAN: Sorry, I didn't
know if it was public or not.
My mistake.
Thanks for the question.
It allowed us to highlight
a new feature
or an upcoming feature.
Yeah, sorry.
AUDIENCE: I understand that we
have to pay for bandwidth when
we're talking between App
Engine instances.
Is that going to be free
at some point?
BRIAN QUINLAN: I have
no information on
pricing changes there.
But I suspect not, because
a PM is nodding his head.
But once again, he is
available for your
haranguement or other
entertainment, if you want to
have a go at him.
Anything else?
Or should I start giving
away stuff?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
BRIAN QUINLAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: I want you to start
giving away stuff, but are you
still working on startup time
at all, to reduce that a
little bit?
BRIAN QUINLAN: I am, personally,
not working on
startup time.
I'm trying to think if anyone's
doing anything to
reduce startup time right now.
I don't think so, actually.
But feel free to talk to me,
if you're hitting some case
where startup time is slow.
AUDIENCE: OK.
BRIAN QUINLAN: Cool.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN QUINLAN: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Throw it.
BRIAN QUINLAN: What?
You want me to throw them?
Oh, really?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: No!
No!
BRIAN QUINLAN: No, no, no, no,
I like the throw it into the
crowd strategy.
Ah, it seems so unsafe.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I want one!
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Give me
one for my boss.
He would kill me, if I come
home without one.
BRIAN QUINLAN: Well, if you
have some sort of death
threat, then--
could you go stand with that
group and take your chances?
Oops.
[LAUGHTER]
BRIAN QUINLAN: Oh, sorry,
it wasn't for--
OK.
AUDIENCE: I think we're
out, Brian.
BRIAN QUINLAN: We're out.
Sorry, guys.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].